what up guys welcome to the just pearly
YouTube channel and welcome to the
pregame
before I start do not forget to
subscribe to the channel and ring that
notification Bell that way you're going
to be notified of my daily videos as you
guys already know if you have watched
two or more of my lives and you do not
subscribe we have beef okay beef people
so hit that subscribe button also guys
the like is the most important metric
that YouTube uses to push out these
streams so make sure you like the video
on your way in
um yeah like it please okay so a couple
announcements before we start the show
the first being that we have two clips
channels the first is just pearly clips
and the second is Pearl daily so make
sure you go subscribe to both of those I
have two different editors on those
accounts so you get a little bit
different types of Clips
um the second being is that we have four
membership tiers the first lets you be a
part of the live chat the second you get
to access to our Discord which I'm newly
active in I'm learning how to how to use
it I've heard you know I've gotten some
suggestions so I've been in that chat so
sign up for that you also get behind the
scenes Vlogs the third tier you connect
with me on social media and the fourth
tier you get a one-on-one call with me
once a month I have helped so many
people grow their YouTube channels and
if you want to grow your YouTube channel
I really suggest signing up for a
one-on-one call with me once a month the
second thing we're gonna go over is that
go follow my Instagram it's just dot
pearly things and we just hit 50k on
Instagram
I am Shadow banned so make sure you guys
go follow that because you have to type
out the whole thing for it to come up
also go follow me on Tick Tock they took
away my first second and third Tick Tock
account but they can't get rid of me off
this app so go follow just
pearlythings.4 and just pearlythings.5
um thank you for 440k which is mad
because we just hit 400k like a week ago
yeah
um so thank you guys so much for that um
let me know in the comments what you
guys want us to do for half a million um
and we're gonna do a Members Only Live
soon I'm not sure exactly when Jess when
should we do it
um oh wait after I get back yeah the end
of the month we'll do a we'll do a
Halloween version a spooky version Oh a
Halloween live too yeah for members yep
um that's basically when just me Jess
and blessing after the show We'll order
a pizza and you know do some like behind
the scenes type content answer questions
for you guys
um
I think I feel like I had one more
announcement but I can't remember it
um
yeah I can't remember but um Eddie if
you want to come on the show oh yeah if
you want to come on the show DM Eddie
okay so today
um we have a lovely panel so why don't
we go around everyone say your name your
age your relationship status any social
media you want to plug and a fun fact so
starting here
hi I'm ice cream the post girl I am fine
wine years old I am happily engaged and
a fun fact about me is that I'm really
scared of deep water
like oceans okay what about pools
everything
if it's too deep I'm afraid of oceans
yeah yeah
[Music]
all right cool all you need to know
about me yeah King riches yeah go
subscribe to my YouTube channel that's
all you need to know there's nothing
else yeah go subscribe to my YouTube
channel yeah that's it done you're gonna
hear the rest let's go
and his YouTube channel is in the
description and his YouTube I mean my
YouTube channel is in the description of
course thank you
all right hey guys it's Jess
um I'm 28 years old I'm single and you
can find me on Instagram and YouTube at
your girl justly fun fact
um
I think
I'm the Next Generation in my family to
possibly have twins so that's a fun fact
that's the first one that popped into my
head so yeah so if you guys want if
there's a guy that wants some Twins hit
her up
want it two and done let me know
foreign
fun fact I like doing accents I guess
you're a demonstration what's your
favorite what's your favorite accent to
do no I like doing a British accent okay
give me a sentence real quick
I like doing pretty British accents I
like doing British accents it's not that
bad store listen yeah we'll work listen
yeah we're working on it
that wasn't that bad still that was
really good
uh hi
um Shahara I'm 28 I'm a relationship
and
a fun fact
um I can do impressions as well accents
I mean I like doing them I'm not that
great at them but go and then going in I
don't know what you want uh what's your
best one do your best one I don't know
can you do Spanish
uh
um I I don't know is it is it a Spanish
accent I don't know is it
in Spanish
Espanol
yeah okay I remembered the announcement
that I didn't say before um guys we're
doing super Chats on the screen tonight
so if you guys send super chats um we're
gonna try anyway all right right
blessing
yeah I think I think we got super Chats
on the screen yeah also the number one
super chat today
um we're gonna write whatever you put on
it on the back here at our next live
show so like you'll see it behind me the
next one so anyone that like wants to be
the stream sponsor of the next show
um Super Chat and then you can have like
a sign if you have like a business or
something here you can put it on there
okay so
um today's topic is do modern women want
Sims
um so
um I want to go around what do you guys
think a simp is
and what is the hardest someone has
simped for you
so start here and then go around well um
um I don't know I don't know can't think
I don't know what the heart what the
biggest thing of someone's done for me
um
well I always cry I I've been I always
um my partner always lets like makes me
cry like on special occasions you know
that just does like things for me like
that
um just goes out their way for me kind
of you know to make me feel special do
you feel like that's simping because it
seems like it's reciprocated right okay
what is a Sim to you simp is somebody
like you said that puts a woman in a
pedestal yeah
yeah
I don't think that's a bad thing though
okay yeah do you like sumps
I don't like the word Sim but I wouldn't
call him I wouldn't call my partner a
simp but um
kinda okay okay
well you're saying it's a good thing if
your partner puts you in a pedestal yeah
yeah
interesting okay what's the question
again
what is a simp yeah and what is the
hardest someone has sent for you what is
a sim a guy that he puts a woman on a
pedestal for no reason especially for no
reason even if it's like the girl is not
even his girl it's just a girl but he
puts on a pedestal from day one from the
from the beginning like I'm saying some
guys they operate like that like you
know what I'm saying they just look at
women as in general as like oh your
goddesses Queens when really and truly
she's she's a human being she eats poos
does everything that we do like do you
get what I'm saying so there's that
um simple for me like uh I think it's
just like normal stuff like um because
obviously as a guy it's different girls
don't really tend to simp for guys
really like you know what I mean
um
usually
um when a woman is simp for me is
usually like just spending money on me
when not needing to like oh do you want
me to buy do you want to do that or like
you know just going out of their way
like for instance I had one girl that
you know she would always call me oh do
you need me to drive you here do you
need me to drive you there do you know
what I'm saying and it's like bro I'm
not even I'm just chilling like you're
gonna be it's calm in it cool down but I
appreciate it though yeah I was gonna
say did you like that or no I I kind of
did but at the same time because I
didn't like her that much it kind of
became annoying so I kind of see it from
a girl's point of view when a guy is
simpian for a girl when the girl don't
really like him you're just wasting your
time because that's not gonna make the
girl like you it's gonna make the girl
use you that's all that's gonna happen
in it you know what I'm saying so that
that's my that's my take on that have
you ever stepped for a girl
like do you know what yeah honestly let
me bring them up yes and no yes and no
I'm about to speak what's wrong with
this girl they said yeah at the end of
the day all guys have simped in it oh
guys I remember back in the day back in
the beginning
not no recent team how old like 13
that's how far away yeah okay so you're
you're very removed yeah oh yeah that's
when you just Disney no Aladdin all them
kind of things I just wanna I just want
a nice girl to go picnics with yeah all
of them yeah so boom now I remember one
girl like I just bought a phone case
like I just bought a phone case I was
just thinking I was walking and I saw
Focus I thought raw she would like that
you know and I was boyfriend and then
times I didn't have no peas you don't
say I have no money so I just bought it
and then boom like that was it like you
know what I mean but apart from that
like not really you know
together saying not really still
okay Jess
um a Sim to me is someone who
essentially does something like goes out
of their way for someone that isn't one
deserving of it or two isn't doing
anything so if you just
sitting on the couch not doing anything
and your man's like oh I'll do this for
you I'll do that for you you just have
to sit there do nothing probably Freedom
I'll do everything for you it's just
like
huh I don't I don't I think that's a Sim
but have I ever had anyone so for me no
never not that I can think of
no no no no no one that she registers no
yeah no I'm being serious oh no no why
no no one in the friend zone no okay all
right okay where are you Sasha
um it's kind of like similar to what all
of y'all like what have y'all said so
like a person a simp is a person who
does for another person but like they're
not dating they're not talking you're
not married whatever
um they and they like the person could
treat them like crap but they still do
things for them they'll do it they'll do
whatever they want for them but
um as of I don't think I've ever been a
simp
and I don't think anyone's ever sent
over me unless you count like one time
somebody paid for my nails but I didn't
I don't know who he was like I just met
him yeah
that's the most though yeah
yeah pretty much like everybody was
saying when they're a bit over the top
and um in in terms of their gestures or
like over complimenting a bit too much
and things like that and usually it's
about superficial things
um like looks and stuff and um like
they're not romantically involved
they're just you know complimenting and
I don't know want to do justice for you
um I I have probably simply for somebody
a long time ago
um but I've had somebody sent for me I
hate you from saying that but um I don't
want to say it's I don't want to
embarrass him what if he's watching okay
out of respect I don't know but it was
um yeah like I I felt because I didn't
find him attractive and stuff I was just
like okay stop you know I I have respect
for you and I want you to maintain your
dignity to stop but yeah that's pretty
much it so
that's like the worst way to be let down
yeah because you're so nice about it but
it's like I thought someone said I want
you to stop to remove it so you can
maintain your date to me you know you
know it was it was so bad because I
didn't want to like hurt his feelings
that I was like maybe should I just go
out I was like no no
can I ask you a question can I ask you
two questions what did he do that was
like the major thing that was simply and
the second question why didn't you find
him attractive
uh okay I I didn't find him attractive
because
um uh I me as a person when I'm like
interested in a man it's not about his
job but it's it's more of like the
Hobbies like are you interested he
didn't he wasn't interested in anything
he was interested in you though
um yeah oh okay yeah but didn't that
have been an important that's really
what's important yeah well I'm not a
hobby
like come on it just I didn't um I
remember when he um when I asked him
like do you have like come on you must
have something right because that's like
attractive like yo he has another you
know he's more to his life and
everything like that and then um he said
oh no um when I when I get with you my
life will start and I was like wow
wow yeah so uh hit mad still yeah but I
did help him though I was like hey you
seem like you're interested in this why
don't you go and then I kind of just was
you was you distracted him was he
physically attracted to him
um
I mean he wasn't terrible but because
it's more like the character thing
because because a guy can be average but
when he has a character he's just like
wow
um and I yeah so you did find him
attractive no I I didn't he didn't so
because he was missing that element no
okay no that's yeah anyway
there can be some good looking guys but
if they're just like yeah and
personality you're like so tender it's a
waste of looks yeah so loud so it was it
his personality or his hobbies that
turned you off no but it's personality
and it's like his lack of hobbies
because of his personalities like kind
of just like oh
okay that makes sense yeah I mean what
what goodies looks
I mean you can have good looking
children
right who have no Hobbies
no the kids will have hobbies just the
guy won't yeah yeah but that's their dad
yeah I don't know maybe he wants to
America as long as he makes money it
doesn't matter no
characters
being boring all right let me ask you
basically let me ask you another
question yeah so your ex-boyfriend the
guy that you did get in a relationship
with what was his Hobbies
but I have an ex-boyfriend oh fair
enough oh okay yeah fair enough
um I think I thought you said you simp
for someone earlier oh yeah yeah but I
wasn't like oh it was a boyfriend yeah
yeah at home I don't want to get into
that I was really young okay yeah
um okay so um since we're on the topic
of sense
in the nanosphere there are two sims but
I'm gonna focus on the first one there
is the king of simps they call him
and I personally didn't know who he was
but I found out about him his name is
Derek Jackson okay oh Derek
um I want to know what you guys know of
Derek Jackson
and what what is your opinion on him
I just know he tries to be the
motivation of like helping women and
giving them advice and doing this and
doing that but he ended up cheating on
his wife and then
exposed it to the world yeah and she was
on the side just looking stupid too so I
mean that's the most done I haven't seen
all his videos but I've seen a few but
that was I think that was enough
I used to watch a lot of his videos
because he would be on Instagram and I'd
be like oh some of the stuff that he's
saying it sounds good so I followed him
and seeing like where when he did cheat
on his wife is like you think back to
his videos and it's just like sir when
you were in that car were you leaving or
were you going are you you were telling
on yourself the whole time you're like
man if you don't like your wife if she
looks like this she looks like that you
need to do this if you don't like being
with her how are you going to cheat on
them and then go back to him it's just
like but you did it how are you going to
tell the people not to do it and you did
it can I ask how did it come out that he
uh
does anyone in the chat know how it came
out
um I I know it was like
she was like a doctor or something and I
remember he got her pregnant
and I think there was a couple of things
but yeah oh wow he was hitting it wrong
you know what that reminds me of a like
uh to touch pastors and stuff
unfortunately they're like revealed to
have like prostitutes and oh the one in
a year because they're they're the
homemakers
yeah
because that's why they preach like
forgiveness for the hoes so they can
really compose
they should baptize you
feel like it's okay we preach
forgiveness here he's like marketing
he's like come to my church
yeah that's my theory Chambers
um but um I have a clip from him that
we're gonna watch and I just want to get
you guys take on it
um someone said it was Tasha K was the
one who Okay side chick um Tasha K put
him on blast and the side chick exposed
him okay I could see that happening yeah
I don't really know who I've heard the
name Tasha K I don't really know who she
is she's in problems with cardi B she
needs to chill she just got sued by
having it yeah oh did she read a lot as
well a lot of money sheesh
because she's in everybody's business
no this is another one no this is a
YouTuber yeah it's just like okay okay
she's in everybody's business and she
exposed him and then the woman came out
ah okay
yeah yeah ready
team Jackson what's happening you know
after looking at my comments and seeing
these guys that be getting the arguments
with y'all I've noticed something
reverse psychology is ain't [ __ ] man's
best friend
really anything that's supposed to make
you feel bad for him not being on your
level like it don't matter what he says
it all means he can't handle you I'll
give you some examples you tell me if
you heard him before like say you
watching something on TV and you tell
them your thoughts about it and then you
ask him what his are and he says
something like man you thinking way too
much into it I am not talking about
y'all to be getting legit mad at a man
for some hypothetical [ __ ] that never
happened but if you just try to have a
conversation beyond the surface level he
responds with that he can't handle your
thought process like it should be at
least able to articulate his thoughts as
to why he feels that way but if that's
how he ends every conversation you try
to start that means mentally he's not on
your level and he's blaming you for it
oh here's another one whenever he's been
doing some suspect [ __ ] so you ask him
about it that way you don't overreact
and he responds with you know what you
acting real insecure right now like how
secure are you supposed to be when his
actions are things that could breach
security now when the dude says that
that means he wants you to question your
judgment about something y'all both know
is blurring the line
like if you notice all of a sudden that
your dude is changing his passcode every
few days or deleting text messages or
pressing ignore on Late Night Calls
you're supposed to ask about that it's
just like whenever you log into your
online banking from a new device it asks
you further questions to verify your
identity not because you're doing
something wrong but they want to make
sure that you're not so when you ask a
dude about a new friend girl that you
ain't never met or any of his actions
that make you raise her eyebrow that's
not you being insecure that you
verifying his identity that he's not a
[ __ ] boy another thing he'll say when he
can't handle you it's like whenever he
tried to pop up on you without prior
notice or invite you over to his house
but you not having it so he says you
ain't even giving me a chance but what
he really means is it ain't got nothing
to do with you not giving him a chance
it just means he can't handle the amount
of effort you require for a man to stand
a chance I go to the gym all the time
and see dudes trying to lift weights
they ain't got no business trying to
lift and it's not that the weights won't
give them a chance they just don't have
what it takes to put forth the amount of
effort that's required for that weight
sad part is some guys will tell a woman
that she's not giving him a chance and
she'll actually make herself lighter
instead of telling him he needs to
either get his weight up or go to some
weight that he can handle
no you need to make the effort required
to get close to you not up for
negotiation because in that case the
only chance that you're not giving is
one to a man who's trying to waste your
time
oh here's one when the dude invites you
out to a ratchet ass Hood spot and you
give them a better suggestion or he's
texting you with [ __ ] grammar so you
clarify what he means and he says you
think you all that actually if by all
that he means you don't want to go
places frequently by 40 year olds
SoundCloud rappers that never made it
and you prefer coherent sentences in
your conversations then he might be
right but you know what you should think
that you're all that and you should
entertain a man who thinks the same
instead of dudes who tell you that
you're wrong for the level of quality
you want and how you spend your time and
communicate with them all right I'll
give y'all one more example like when
the dude says see all that you want from
a man that's unrealistic [ __ ] thinking
like that you're gonna stay single
now I made a video about this but it's
worth mentioning again when a guy says
that he means that he and men like him
can't handle the value that you expect
in return in a relationship so you
should feel bad about it but the problem
is in order for women to believe that
they have to believe that all men are as
tired as this guy is and there are too
many examples that prove otherwise
especially for women that were raised by
Good Men they have siblings or family
members that are good men they go to
church with good men they've befriended
good men or they got friends who were
found by good men like there are simply
too many good Brothers out here for
these ain't [ __ ] dudes to keep promoting
themselves as the mascot for all men or
the definition of what's realistic so
please don't go for it so if a dude
tells you anything that essentially
translates to he can't handle you
because he's not on your level leave him
on his and find you a man that's on your
level so you two can go to the next one
together
so this was his most viewed video oh
really yeah so is this recent no it's
not this is
um I think it's older but what do you
guys think
Derek Derek Derek
go ahead King isn't it so ironic that
you were saying all these things you was
obviously talking about yourself
Derek you cheated on your wife you was
probably cheating on your wife when you
made that video like I find it amazing
that you have the confidence to come out
in your car with your little dry fit
vest talking about oh a guy can't handle
you if he says this if he says that bro
those are lines out of your playbook bro
what are you talking about
bro like this is just crazy and really
and truly any woman that follows Derek
Jackson you're just gullible and just
dumb yeah I'm saying at the end of the
day this guy is just he's just pandering
and simping for the affection and the
attention of gullible desperate women at
the end of the day it's just he's just
selling you like a dream he couldn't
even sell his own wife a dream because
he got exposed but like it's a joke in
it he talks like a girl he talks like a
[ __ ] really and truly and he he never
says anything like advocating for guys
and he's talking about oh um find you a
guy and and there's all good guys out
there but you're not one of them Derek
like what are you talking about like
this guy's just annoying bro like he
just gets me heated in it because at the
end of the day he's trying to sell a
dream he and he's not even that dream
himself the only reason he gets played
and a lot of women like to listen to him
is because they probably are attracted
to him and find him attractive that's
that's literally it he's saying what
these women want to hear they're
gullible and he's six foot four he's
built like an NFL tight end so obviously
boom that's it and he's got money so in
their eyes he's a high value man and
even when he got found out for
fornicating on his wife who had a child
for him that like he's still got a
following so I just find this to be a
quite amazing to be honest I don't know
what you love thinks but anyway I think
he's corny he gives advice that he can't
take and when he talks he sounds like
he's talking about his personal stuff
and he sounds like he's overly trying to
be convincing
so his voice to me doesn't sound
authentic you know like it's quite
scripted like he's trying to convince
you of what he's saying too much it just
doesn't come across like he's speaking
from the heart so he always kind of
seemed corny to me anyway do you know
what I mean so yeah
um but in when you first when you first
came across Derek Jackson did you think
he was corny or did you think no I like
what you're saying because I think a lot
of women they a lot of women did like
what he said initially because it kind
of feeds into how you like some of the
things that he's saying you know it's
like the message is there but I don't
know it's like he can't deliver it in
the right way to me I can see that he's
a narcissist even before he got caught
because he's talked so much I think he
over kills it when he's trying to
explain something he's speaking so much
because he loves camera time he he
speaks to women so much because that's
who he wants to attract he's not
speaking to men because he doesn't want
men in his DMS he wants women oh yeah
the attention of women that's why he's
so trying to yeah he's like the pastor
yeah he wants not all part not all
pastors but I know that yeah but um yeah
that's that's what I get her from him
and men will call him out anyway yeah
exactly that's what I was going to say
yeah and he so he deliberately he's just
like okay I'm gonna go here because
they'll just believe what whatever I'm
gonna say the small man will that he was
talking about
like the chicken shop or the taco shop
that the 40 year olds are I'm like where
what type of guys do you guys date like
I'm just confused
I just find I just find it to be a joke
really and like no one should ever take
him seriously and anyone that does take
him seriously bro don't be surprised if
your life goes to ruin brother his wife
stayed with him though didn't she and
she said in my opinion she's silly for
that at first um they got divorced oh
they did oh I didn't know that
um I'm pretty sure I'm gonna double
check but I swear but think about the
psychology of that though think about
the psychology of him like he's spewing
all of this rhetoric and cheating
now it's not even like he's going in
general he's going straight at the guys
you guys and these women deserve better
blah blah blah what about your own wife
bro exactly you're talking about that's
usually how they tell on themselves they
can't stop talking about it yeah so it's
like they're trying to cover their
tracks in a way and when you can with
somebody that was giving out so much
advice you know like if you claim to be
such a perfect man in the perfect
relationship and that you're supposed
poster can look at somebody's wife and
just instantly tell that she's happy she
just looks so tired in that but if she
looks higher than that Bonnet
do you understand like she was so tired
of him did you get what I mean you know
it didn't even look like somebody that
said okay we're human he's made a
mistake and I'm standing by my husband
it wasn't even that she did he just
looked like he constantly uses um
Mind Games to just tear her down to make
her feel like she needs him do you
understand what I mean those are the
type of men that just
um eat away at your um self-confidence
to get me can you imagine like being in
her shoes where I mean because I doubt
that was the first time she caught him
cheating like I'm sure it was I'm sure
it happened more than once and just
listening he said to your husband like
do these talks I was just gonna say yeah
that makes it ten thousand times worse
I just can't think like oh my God she
probably thinks he's so full of [ __ ]
because she knows all of it that's what
I'm saying the psychology behind it is
mad like do you get what I'm saying like
so
yeah man he's just full of crap to be
honest like he's a joke in my opinion
the funny thing is he's still making
money from his little talks and
everything other people are still
listening to him after all the stuff
that he's done so so hold on okay so
women don't want to get cheated on but
they're following a man who says the
right things who cheated on his wife
because then women don't want to accept
accountability yeah and he's in the
right package
he's tall he's big he's got money
there you go because like let's keep it
real the majority of his audience are
the type of women that would be
attracted to a guy like that
specifically do you get what I'm saying
so that's easy that's that's a monopoly
straight away now yeah he probably lost
some of his fan base boom boom boom but
there's gonna be some that well you know
well you know give him a second chance
so this is this is the thing they're
never consistent with the outrage with
like they're never consistent they're
always like you know if you find
something consistently bad will be no
matter what happens if a family member
does it or somebody but they always kind
of change it make excuses and everything
for whoever you like yeah makes excuses
for whoever you like
yeah last thing you want to show the
next clip from him oh God
thanks to the two tick tocks
Michael suggested this one I suggested
these he must be stopped
I just can't imagine like why would you
still follow him after because they won
they want his sausage that's why I lost
a lot of subscribers they said
afterwards I want to see how many he's
got I think he did I think he lost like
a lot of subscribers let me see I just
want to see I think another thing is if
you subscribe it that takes a lot of
like you have to admit now that all of
it's a fad like you know he's a liar
everything he's saying is all [ __ ]
and everything like that so 674
000 subscribers
at a time as well that yeah doing
seminars
his views are definitely low but like
they're not bad they're not horrible
he's still he's still an in living no no
just pearly things views you know what I
mean
obviously obviously
is he a dad
yeah oh yeah can you imagine being his
kid no oh my God
trips me out it's like we say women got
the unrealistic expectations and some of
them do but ain't nobody got more
unicorn fairy tale Dora the Explorer
expectations of the opposite sex than us
men again some women do expect a man to
be six feet tall and make six figures
and have a six pack abs and that's
unrealistic for most men but I know like
10 dudes already that fit into that
category all you got to do is have a
good job and some good genetics and you
straight but look at us like how what do
we expect of a woman she got to be a
virgin but she gotta be a freak she
gotta pay half the bills but she got to
do 100 of the cleaning the cooking the
child raising she gotta be exhausted
from all of that you know all the
cooking and washing the cleaning and all
that good stuff and still be horny
enough to meet our sexual needs and get
a good night's rest but also wake up in
the middle of the night in case we want
some head and a turkey sandwich that
ain't it she also gotta give birth to
all our babies because you know we gotta
have that Legacy but then she can't have
no stretch marks and she got to lose
that baby weight in 30 days or less and
and then she got to do it while fighting
postpartum depression by herself because
we're gonna tell her she have an
attitude or something like that because
all we thinking about is we ain't got no
vagina in the last six weeks that she
gotta take to heal that ain't it then
she can get older but she can't look
older otherwise we're gonna say that
she's falling off like the list goes on
but just tell me something how many
women do you know that fit into that
category none
so who really got the unrealistic
expectations
sir it's so offensive
ladies are we watched another one no no
we'll go back to the next one later it's
like did you did you have those
unrealistic expectations yeah finger
like when your wife was pregnant and
your wife had those children like are
you just saying all the things that you
did while your wife was going through
all this I don't hear God guys really
demand that high of expectation I have a
single guy
that that genuinely expects a virgin I I
don't know one
I mean I think some of them are like I'd
be nice but I don't think men are that
delusional no we live in 2022 wait
there's a handful of women
may I say one thing I'll just put my
hand up man I'll say one thing this guy
said just have a job and good genetics
like that's something that you can pick
you know pick your genetics Derek
like what are you talking about oh I
know I know at least 10 guys just
because you're six foot four Derek it
doesn't mean that that's just something
that's handed out like that exactly this
guy's an idiot Ralph like what the vast
majority of men are under six foot so
saying just have good genetics I broke
like what kind of world do you live in
bro like I didn't know when you was born
you could just say oh I would like to be
six foot four like bro like it doesn't
go like that bro so like he's already
leading women down a road of failure
because he's trying to make it out like
oh yeah you know these unrealistic
expectations or did this small minority
oh that's easy to find there's there's
loads of guys like that no it's not but
I think everyone needs to be more
realistic and again just just like Jess
said a lot of the things he's talking
about bro you slept with a side chick or
a couple side chicks behind your woman's
back and you had a kid so how dare you
talk about other guys bro that is it's
actually he makes my blood boil like I
swear like he makes my blood boil like
he's just saying anything and he's
actually making the dating Market harder
for everyone not just guys for everybody
because now women are walking around
with these delusional expectations
because Derek Jackson said yeah that
yeah actually that makes sense no it
doesn't make sense bro
you know what I'm saying like it's a
joke thing and what percent of guys even
make six figures it's like less than ten
percent yeah he was saying that oh yeah
just get a job bro like come on bro like
that's that's unrealistic absolutely
unrealistic
I don't know if you look
no that's so offensive like I'm not a
man but obviously but um like most men
obviously they're just decent normal
reasonable man good man and he's saying
oh yeah every man wants this this and
literally making women like drumming up
them their hatred for men and so she
would I guarantee you should look out
the window and be like yeah I hate him
like some random man
yeah because Derek Jackson says he knows
at least 10 guys that make six figures
that are over six foot so if you don't
come into that category then ah forget
about you when that could be her husband
yeah exactly what I'm saying she could
be happy and then the one thing he said
that was actually that I just chuckled
to he said oh when um you want your
woman to have babies for you for your
legacy really truly like to be honest
with you it's usually women that push to
have kids more than guys bro really you
know what I'm saying I don't know about
one of my ex-girlfriends she wanted a
kid bad and I had to just stop sleeping
with her because I was scared she was
gonna do that you know what I'm saying
so all of that is a joke then he was
like oh yeah
um when when you have a kid for your man
he wants you to lose all the weight in
30 days or less brav what are you
talking about you now you're just making
up nonsense like you're just making up
stories bro like and again just like you
said it's gonna cause more of a division
between women because the women because
he's saying stuff that he knows women
want to hear extreme extreme dreams that
is going to make pump them up to feel
like yeah men are they are unreasonable
they're evil do you get what I'm saying
he's an idiot his normal is toxic
that's what it looks like to me like
what he uses as his examples are toxic
Behavior anyway and I'm realisticated
yeah he's appealing to women that are
having like they find it hard getting a
partner to understand so and now it's
even harder if they're listening to him
it's ridiculous I don't think he really
cares what he's saying at this well at
that point even now because he still
makes videos yeah so and they keep
following they keep subscribing maybe
not as much as they used to but you
still have people following somebody
that
just actually tells you just what you
want to hear or what women want to hear
because his main
his main
his main audience is women
um do you think that the simps are part
of the problem with all the delusional
women these days
Sims yes Sims absolutely
absolutely man because if it wasn't for
The Sims here
like it kind of enables the delusion in
a lot of the modern women today to get
what I'm saying if it was just like
playing black and white okay men like
like these type of women they like these
type of traits they have these kind of
expectations which in my opinion I think
men are quite simple and easy to please
yeah like right it will kind of just be
plain sailing like women would know what
to do men would know what to do like
it's just like men know we women want to
be protected and and provided for men
know that do you get what I'm saying
there's not really no pushback with that
but in today's time you've got Sims that
will will come out here and be like oh
yeah you got to do all this and no
matter what the woman's doing you still
need to protect and provide for her even
though she's not a traditional woman do
you understand do you think modern women
deserve to be courted
no one deserves nothing breath
that's what I'm saying from
yeah what do you think
recorded
all my modern women too
yeah deserve
I think they should why not
but deserved though that's the that's
the key word no because because I think
like if you're not traditional how can
you expect a traditional outcome
yeah do they want to be courted
I mean I think girls like say that but
they don't typically yeah that's what
I'm saying like pick the guys that Court
them
they want the bad boys that's what they
want
yeah my boys they don't do courtship do
they bad boys don't talk bad boys smash
bad boy smash first date yeah
yeah yeah yeah
what are you looking at me bad boys take
girls out on dates
they do I think so as well one day
sometimes one day might be a cheap one
still
like what's the what's the max twenty
dollars not fifty fifty fifty fifty
fifty pound no pound pound pound Pound
fifteen pound Max okay
oh my God
you think
I think that they should cut I think
that they should be caught in brought
back into relationships because I feel
like it would just balance everything
how it makes it if you keep doing
something it's going to become its norm
and that's why I just feel like there's
masculine women
because of the the imbalance of what of
the roles what the men and women are
supposed to have I strongly believe that
men and women are completely two
different two different people do you
understand we look at things differently
we're designed differently and the
moment that we more understand that the
better that we'll get along then it's
easier to find your compatibility and
stuff like that courtship is getting to
know somebody courtship is Shane respect
to somebody courtship is showing
somebody how special you think they are
those are the type of things that women
like to have yeah so that's that's why I
look at those things that's why I think
that those things should happen so when
you say modern women I look at modern as
you mean in this day and time that we
are now of course because if you don't
do it then like our children our
daughters to come and stuff they're not
going to have any of that you kind of
have to I think it's just like wait for
the next round of 22 year olds yeah I
think I think I think our area is done
to be honest because at the end of the
day like all what you're saying is all
well and good calm yeah but the real the
reality the reality is like okay say I
want to record the average modern chick
walking around typical girl walking
around she's probably talking to at
least five to ten other guys she's
probably sleeping with one or two other
guys bro like why am I gonna Court her
it's a different time that whole
courting thing in my opinion it kind of
refers to an older time like a more
traditional time where the women were
traditional the men were traditional and
it made sense to call girls because you
knew she wasn't sleeping around you knew
she didn't throw a box around bro you
know I'm saying whereas now bro like
once you hit 25 most girls you you're
going to encounter have thrown their box
around considerably but even if they
want to forget about the guys that
didn't do it well or they just didn't
like that much they they've done a lot
do you get what I'm saying so the
quoting thing deserve I wouldn't agree
with deserve if you if you come across a
decent woman then yeah she can get
courted but I what's the percentage of
decent women walking around that's
debatable in it what do you think it is
what a passage yeah
um ah bruh with all social media
Instagram you know cardi B city girls
the influence especially in the UK
influence of uh American
bruh oh no bruh I reckon it's like
15 15. yeah 15. I honestly think that
because and that's going from my
experience and the experience of the
guys that I know the things that girls
I've had entanglements with what they've
said do you know I mean like bro like
you know I've I've been in situations
where I'm sleeping with a girl and then
the girl's on hinge going out on dates
and then she's coming back telling me
how the date went and I'm sleeping with
her again
that's like obviously that's good for me
like you could call me a scumbag I don't
care that's good for me but for that guy
that women paid for that he's courting
her
that's a joke to me and then from like a
guy's point of view it's just like the
it's almost like the the cast that way
the benefits because it's like you're
spending money and your time and your
attention on a girl but like what do you
get in return the average age of first
marriage in the UK is 31 so you don't
get Youth and you don't get Purity
anymore you get used to books yeah and
so it's like and you don't really get
loyalty anymore because the divorce rate
is 50 and women leave 70 to 80 percent
of the time 90 of their college educated
so it's kind of like the juice isn't
really worth the squeeze from the man's
point of view and then if she if she
divorces you she's taking the kids away
so if she's paid too she's paid to take
the kids away there you go
yeah that makes sense
there's a matching out here
so basically we're you're saying is you
don't think there's hardly any decent
women out here no do you guys do you
women agree with that
I think from like 1950s standards I
would agree yeah I think that's 100 True
like women back then were virgins they
had cookbooks they were wives I don't
think most women today were raised to be
wives they weren't raised by wives how
would they know how to be one
and a lot of girls wasn't raised with
their father as well that's another
aspect in that as well again and I just
think we live in a very selfish culture
where it's me me and like when you're
traditional like you believe in the
family before me but like how many how
many women are willing to give up their
dreams for a man
how many women women are really willing
to put the family first
yeah I will agree
um with pearl there's been some things
that I've seen on TV and I just been
like man is this how
women are portraying themselves nowadays
and it's just the same type of woman and
I like think like do y'all wonder why
like you're single or you have baby
daddies or XYZ it's like do you ever
think about your actions and then um
something that project said about
um women will leave men for their
careers instead of staying with them
there was this uh post that I saw there
was a woman she was with some she was
with a man that took care of her house
paid for everything and she wanted to
become an actor she left went to I think
was Atlanta and she wanted to pursue her
dream in acting got there
didn't do acting became a stripper got
pregnant and she was like maybe I should
go back to him so he can help me
while she's pregnant it's just like it
just doesn't make sense and I think of
like my grandparents generation where my
Grandma had 13 kids for my grandpa like
I I know guys that want like five six
like a lot of children they can't find
someone that wants to do that for them
like most women only want one or two
kids because they don't like it's like
more about them and their lifestyle
rather than having as many kids as
possible like like the women back then
used to want kids they want to do it
early they wanted as many as they
possibly could because there was no
security
I think if you was um if you're from a
time where you're able to live out your
role which is like you know you stay at
home and you have your children you feel
secure within that I feel like nowadays
women are in relationships and they're
always looking they're always thinking
like it might not work out I might get
divorced but I might need a backup plan
because men ain't supplying the same
security as back in the day because
they're not staying in the homes do you
mean money or you mean I mean security
is financial and emotional as well okay
if a woman feels Totally Secure within
our mind I believe that that's when she
will feel feminine enough to give you
loads of kids a woman that feels that
she has to go out and do something for
herself is because she's in a
relationship is because she's not being
fulfilled properly by her man simple
because if you're in a traditional
relationship the man is the provider
when the woman's the Homemaker do you
understand but the problem is women
won't go down in lifestyle in order to
have a family so like
so no I I think women are more I'll give
you an example okay and I don't I don't
mean to pick on you but like you your
nails done right yeah and I noticed most
girls that come on my show have their
nails done and they they usually have
very nice clothes and it's like it's
like lifestyle
but and and so like I've asked this
question where I say would you go down
in lifestyle like you make this much
money would you go down to this
lifestyle at forty thousand thirty
thousand dollars to a year for a family
and they say no
like because a man on one income you can
afford an apartment but women want a
house if you go down buy that much money
because children cost money
and though that's the realest that's the
reality of it so if you can't just sit
down and just you you can't just say I'm
gonna just have five children like that
but back then they used to like figure
it out so like my dad my dad was one of
13 kids and they would do hand-me-downs
like they lived off of one salary it was
a fireman's salary it wasn't a ton of
money they just lived poor because it
was always about the family first but
like women don't want to do that there
ain't no women now that want to live but
like women not want to live Instagram
lifestyle bro that's why I look at them
on Instagram bro that's why a lot of
them are on Instagram taking pictures of
the plate of food that they're eating
RAF
come on bro come on like they dig from
the uh what's it the music video vixen
girl to the Girl Next Door they're all
doing the same thing bro it's the same
programming so if a guy can't provide
XYZ they're not going for it bro they're
just not bro like hypergamy is on story
it's like in this in this era or even
like I think about how my mom like she
got she got like a top half a percent
guy right but she quit her Josh she was
a teacher she quit her job to go work
for him he said if you want to be with
me like you need to move otherwise like
go find a new boyfriend she said okay
I'm gonna quit I'm gonna come to you but
like how many women nowadays are willing
to quit their job for a man that has no
money because he had no money
she obviously could see his potential
and she allowed him to lead not believe
that you should let your man lead but
not make some idiot may lead you because
he's leading you into nowhere sometimes
do you understand what I mean that
that's what I feel like we keep talking
about the women but with me I think it
goes back on to the men women adapt do
you understand they've only they're
they're taking pictures of plates on
their own because it's been normalized
because everybody's hiding and they're
not showing PDA so women are now saying
right that's it we're just going to show
the plates do you know what I mean I've
never gone through that because I've
always been in a relationship my mum's
always been a relationship my grandma's
always been in a relationship do you
think you represent like the typical
modern woman walking out there saying
that they're not decent I definitely
don't represent that no then we should
really focus on what the majority is
because that's the majority of girls
walking around what you're saying but
some people can say that you attract
what you are do you understand I believe
that social media and and the media
portrays a certain type
I'm in a beauty industry and I don't
come across just people in the social
media that I see in social media on a
day-to-day basis that isn't just what is
out there I don't agree there's no
absolutes there's no absolutely you know
what I mean there's no absolutes no one
said I don't think all of most of the
women I don't think majority of the
women are just how many women have you
dated
I don't date women exactly so you don't
really know what you're talking about
all the time it doesn't matter what you
say it doesn't matter because you don't
date them so you don't know what you're
talking about I do know what I'm talking
about but you haven't done it I just
disagree with the fact that I just I
just started so you don't know what
every woman is though that's the same
that's that I'm talking yeah
you haven't been with every woman no but
I'm not saying I never said all and I
said that before I said that before I
think that's very that's my that's my um
so if okay
let's let's
why if if that's true why is it that 50
of women that hit 30 are single and
childless
I'm not sure
I don't know I can't answer that
question but I just believe because if
they were if they were like the women
that men wanted they wouldn't be single
like I don't I don't think men have
changed I think women have because when
we got birth control that's when you see
the divorce rates Skyrocket if you pull
up a chart of like the divorce rate and
the birth control like the number of
women on birth control that's when it's
Skyrocket so when these hoes came to the
streets
[Laughter]
I hear what you're saying and you made a
a point a few minutes ago about how
um if a woman doesn't feel secure with a
man she's gonna do
um x y z to feel secure or just leave I
think they're I think women have shifted
to where they've are doing stuff on
their own doing stuff that men usually
would so when a man comes in and does
that for them they're like I don't need
you to do that for me I can do that on
my own show me something else that you
can do for me to for me to have you in
my life for me to have you in that place
and a man's like well I'm doing what I
am supposed to do but I'm not able to do
it because you're doing it as well and
you're not being in your femininity for
me to be able to show you that I am
doing the manly thing I need to do so
women are like oh he's not this he's not
that because he's not doing it and it's
like how can you have someone do
something for you if you're not giving
them room enough to do it to be them and
it's not is not comfortable for them to
do it I think I would say this I think
that a lot of women like I do get where
you're coming from I think that a lot of
women don't trust men but the reason why
a lot of women these days like modern
women don't trust men is because they
didn't have a dad so if you didn't have
a dad initially in the foundation yeah
and then probably you've just seen your
mum struggle get money do everything by
yourself then she's probably taught you
just oh you know what do it by yourself
don't ever depend on a man yeah
obviously you're never gonna trust a man
because the first man in your life
wasn't there he he failed you yeah you
know what I'm saying and I think but
then if you go deeper into that I think
that happens because a lot of times
women make poor choices in men
and so like I don't really want to say
oh it's all women's for or it's all
mental but we have to be realistic in
this thing in it to get them saying
um and yeah I agree with what Jess said
you know women women out here are doing
more for themselves and that's that that
boils down to like over consumerism
because women spend the most money they
they they're looking at Instagram oh
look at that car look at them shoes look
at that bag I want that so they will go
with the extra mile to getting things
but then when they come across a guy who
may be the right guy for them but may
not be able to buy all those things
that's when the conflict comes see what
I'm saying that's when oh I only want to
date a guy that's gonna take me to
hakasan another cough and them kind of
things but them kind of guys bro they're
just gonna use you bro so again that's
more poor choices then the more poor
choices you make the more baggage you
get the more bitter you become and then
brother like you're done because at some
point you probably become a baby mama at
some point and then the guys that you
like don't want to don't want nothing no
commitment with you they just want to
use you and the cycle continues and then
you bring another generation that does
the same thing
yeah it responds to that no I agree
you've got a point I agree I I think
like um women definitely do make poor
choices in men but um the quality of men
have kind of gone down
I don't think the quality of men has got
I really think it's the women but I in I
think so in in just regards to like you
said the father wasn't there this wasn't
there but I think sometimes people have
to take accountability like you said I
totally agree about taking poor choices
but once something has happened to part
of being a man is finding Solutions you
understand and rectifying certain things
so you see like like if you have a child
or something and it might not have been
the ideal situation but it's now your
responsibility to you know to be a good
father to your children do you
understand what I mean yeah so therefore
they're not going to grow up with as
much Daddy Issues not just leave them
well I think that's the women's fault
though like yeah because they picked
them like why are you sleeping with him
like why are you letting him like why
aren't you on birth control we have 41
forms of birth control pick one
and like why are you why are you letting
a bat a guy that would be a bad dad get
you pregnant like that that's stupid
like what you can't change men and like
as women I think innately we know who's
gonna stick around we know who isn't so
why would you pick him and really and
truly it's a small percentage of guys
that are out here making baby making
machines bro it's a small percentage bro
it's the guys that the guys that
aesthetically look like Derek Jackson
bro
do you get what I'm saying like the guy
the the five foot five guy is not the
one that's causing all the problems out
here it's not bro it's a six foot three
six foot fire for like Charming guy
did you get what I'm saying that is
causing the problem so reading truly bro
it comes down to girls because initially
it's the woman who chooses do you get
what I'm saying and the women typically
leave too like like because the The
Narrative is that like men are the one
sleeping and we can't trust men because
they might leave but women leave more
than men do I was gonna say as well like
I mean I think because you were in a
divorce court or a divorce yes a major
major reason why I see that women are
you know men have pretty much stayed the
same in terms of very not simple and
derogative way but these very basic
stuff you know not have high standards
of what a woman should bring but um
women have gone to universities got
degrees and you know all that stuff
in in recent years so that has been a
major factor in them thinking oh you
know what I could do better and that's
where hypergamy comes in
women have never had the skills like to
this level ever before and where men
have kind of stayed the same you know
they're they're the Breadwinners but now
when the woman can out earn him
naturally she'll be like oh I could do
better than him like what can he offer
me and that's really unfair because is
that his worth like just what he can
offer financially if the children are
eating the children are fed and like
Babe's closed so when she gets too
comfortable where you know what then she
starts thinking well I could just if I
can out earn him like what do I need him
for
um whether that's good or bad is
something else but then she has that
mentality because
yeah I think that's the main reason why
women you can see the change that women
have made and men have stayed the same
you got you got chicks that are doing
only fans yeah selling their body online
making a lot of money because of simps
again and then obviously even they will
have higher expectations because they oh
I'm making 10 racks a month so you know
I need to be with a guy that makes x
amount bruh like it just kind of messes
up the whole game like women are looking
down on 95 yeah
can't win I've done so many reaction
videos to women saying ah nah if a guy
does 95 he they would rather they'd
actually rather date a criminal a
scammer than date a guy that does nine
to five because oh if I just want to go
to Italy at the drop of a hat he can't
do that he has to ask his boss and yeah
I need a guy that's an entrepreneur or a
scammer bro this is unrealistic boss
I've seen too many videos like that yeah
all in the UK and the USA this is normal
stuff do you think guys like Derek
Jackson know what they're doing
absolutely yeah yeah
absolutely they're they're Jackson is
hitting a target audience and the
majority of them are black women and he
knows that if I can get them I have them
hooked and it's sad to say but they're
going to
keep going because I'm not sure if this
stat is correct but I think that the
highest like unmarried demographic is
um one of the highest I was gonna say
one of the highest is black woman and he
knows that if I
what he's saying is it feeding into
everything that is
them essentially
and it's it's hard to say because I am a
black woman and I I remember when I
first saw him and I was like oh yeah
like what he's saying is true like that
makes perfect sense and I really started
listening to him and I was and then all
that stuff happened like I said earlier
and I was like wait let me actually
listen and I had friends who we would
talk about things that he said and sit
down and be like oh did you see his
video today and just discuss it and it's
very
is very disheartening when people hear
something but don't actually like listen
and like think about it but they just
take it and they run with it well and I
think a lot of stuff like simply guys
kind of say it sounds nice and it works
well in theory like raise your standards
but it only works well like if you have
anything to offer a guy
and most modern women don't like how
many modern women have cookbooks how
many modern women are virgins
beans on toast not the fruit beans
which is like it doesn't mean you're a
bad person or anything but it's just
like
um you know it's like you're you're
asking for BMW prices when you're a used
Honda Civic how many buyers you gonna
get
and if you do get a buyer you know damn
well you scam the man and all these
girls and and then them particular girls
you're talking about if you ask them
would you rate yourself out of 10 I'm a
10.
like so some will say 12 actually don't
forget it's mad I break the scale that's
what they say in Life or would you bring
all the worst one you're asking what do
you bring to the table table like
what's his name Derek if he rated people
like his fans oh that would be good that
would be really good he's gonna say yeah
yeah you guys are tense yeah yeah
you literally have to I oh my God I
would kill to get that man on the show
uh I I don't know after this no I think
it'd be funny like I don't know I feel
like you can make some funny content ah
it'd be good though interesting
I would ask him I'd be like why are you
simple and like what are you doing here
I don't think he'd come on I don't know
I just have a feeling the heat will be
too much
um do the next clip blessing
is there anyone you can think of who's a
bigger scent than Derek Jackson
this next person or the one we're about
to watch later oh you think he's bigger
no I don't
he is
nowhere
I mean
there's more Sims out there trust me
once you see it you cannot see it I'm
about to ruin so many dating
she losing
and that applies here secondly I get it
it's like well she's taking everything I
invested into him no she ain't she about
to take everything he was using to
stress you out while blaming it on you
she just don't know it yet and it seems
like he's able to give her you know all
of these different fruits of of your
labor you know all of this good
treatment this money whatever he was
only able to do that because he was
giving you the rest of him he was giving
her the best while giving you the rest
now that she's in your spot he about to
give her the rest he's about to give her
all of that depression he was projecting
onto you because he don't need no
therapist that's what she about to get
that's all she's taken from you she's
taking his criticism whenever his money
get low she's about to take on all of
that neglect those excuses how little
that he was willing to help you around
the house and but whenever he took out
the trash once a week he wanted to be
treated like a cane That's what she
about to get she again she just don't
know it yet everything that he was
blaming on you she about to realize you
were not the problem and on top of that
she's no longer the new toy boy and he
still needs that spot filled now that
she's taking on yours he still needs
that spot filled because we're not
talking about a guy that made his
mistakes he did his wrong but you know
he wants to make it right he's repenting
no we're talking about a guy that
stepped out moved out and he don't see
nothing wrong with it man what that girl
took from you was a blessing to you you
need to be thanking her and somebody
need to be praying for her because she
next
oh
I have a feeling that he is he talking
to anybody is this like from like a show
or anything I don't know Michael you got
it I don't know what he's saying I don't
know he always have a feeling that he's
like sitting in his room acting like
he's talking to somebody but he's not
talking anymore but it's not the corner
of the room yeah it's the it again I was
like is this you are you just exposing
Yourself by saying all this stuff it I
want to know what what people he knows
because I've
it's just like mind-blowing at the stuff
he's saying because it doesn't it
doesn't seem realistic the things that
he's saying I'm like the people that you
know really act like this and are really
doing these things or are or was this
just your story and you're just
portraying as it's somebody that you
know now imagine being his wife like
hearing him tell us
she's like you don't help her on the
house that was you you took a trash out
once and you wanted to be treated like a
king the rest of you you were streaming
depression on me it was you I by his own
logic his wife should have left him by
his own logic she did yeah but I mean
indefinitely Yeah by his logic divorced
like so he's just saying anything again
you know do as I say not as I do
crap I think he's just playing he just
knows what sells he knows he can just
drum up the audience he can get his
subscribers it's very common it's really
shallow he's doing what he's preaching
himself so and he says a lot in in the
video it's not it's not really a quick
video he's saying a lot of things so all
it is is women feel good women feel good
it's not your fault it's the man's fault
yeah bro like it's it's a it's a trick
has he ever done a video like opposite
where he's like trying to balance out
you know the field and oh no
all the [ __ ] I've seen is
Sam I have not seen it's really really
like offensive to men like even the
therapy and all that stuff like that's a
sensitive topic that's why no one don't
like you yeah
you never hear those guys say yes Derek
come on his wife's in the background
probably saying I told you to get
therapy you narcissist
yo she should come out with her own
channel I was Derek Jackson's wife tells
off
just give dating advice and not say his
name
how to spot a narcissist yeah come on I
knew somebody that went through this aka
me
if you're ever in this situation I mean
he made
he made that's true I do have a question
for the ladies uh Derek said something
in his uh first video about
the realistic
uh qualities that a man wants for a
woman and he was talking about oh we
want our
um or unrealistic sorry we want our
woman to cook clean and then
um have sex with us and then cook us
dinner if a man was a pain everything
for you and all he asked for you was to
cook clean make sure everything's
straightened at the house take care of
the kids and then pleasure him would you
think that's an unrealistic ask of him
to do no no no I don't think so either
that's a very healthy man-woman
relationship that's it what if he wasn't
paying all the bills do you still think
that that's okay
um
if it's like
so um obviously we're doing like half
and half bills or whatever yeah 50 50. I
feel like
hmm
with that I think
there should be more roles for the both
of us then like more equal roles
um if we're both making that if we're
both paying bills or it's like even even
50 50 whatever
um I think you should both be
taking on more roles I would try to
balance it more I guess you could say so
I would say it did it depends on
the type of the type of like one who's
ever home more but the type of job that
the woman may have because I feel like
nowadays
a lot of people can work from home but I
see that more men still go into work so
if the wife is working from home she can
do it the job and still do XYZ and then
still be ready for her man when she come
home
foreign
don't you think that men do things like
fixing stuff around the house
and like they're expected to like fix
things mow the lawn yeah so then even if
it's 50 50 shouldn't we still be
expected to do those things
oh yeah I think so I would but I don't
want you to be looking I don't want to
be exhausted it has to kind of balance
like if I'm meeting you a bit halfway I
still I'm still because I'm a woman and
that's just in me anyway like I'm not
gonna stop being a homemaker do you
understand what I mean but obviously I'm
not I don't want to be doing all of it
and I'm completely tired and there you
can help me do you understand because
then I'm gonna feel like I'm being taken
advantage of do you think men would say
the same thing for like you know fixing
stuff around the house mowing the lawn
yard work
[Laughter]
um because if he's like mowing the lawn
and doing work around the house right so
then she would be doing laundry washing
dishes and doing you know whatever else
there's still that balance there unless
really I feel like actually to move the
Lord and do that don't you know
our jobs are easier nowadays but yeah I
mean we got [ __ ] automated dishwasher
dishwasher laundry machine
nice cool call I would I would rather do
that I hate mowing the lawn actually
I've never mowed the lawn
mowing the lawn they responds the cars
they would like they would do the boy
stuff can I see one finger yeah
something that's very uh underrated by
women what is very important protection
because at the end of the day yeah let's
say me and you we was in the house we
got kids who's a protector me or you
me that's a dangerous job that's a
that's a constant job that's a forever
job if me and you are outside and
somebody tries to violate who's got to
be the hero me or you me who's gonna
risk their life in a dangerous situation
me so at the end of the day I listen I
agree with you if the if if the bills
are being like 50 50 then yeah you're
gonna share some responsibilities but at
the end of the day
the life or death situations always
gonna boil down to the man even if the
man is five foot two he's still gonna
boil down to the man breath do you keep
saying and I think that's very
undervalued by women that's a very bro
like being a man is a dangerous role in
life there's a like for instance yeah
you can be outside with a girl who's
good-looking right you go to certain
venues and everybody knows London is
quite dangerous these days yeah bro like
you could go to certain venues and guys
could be angry at you because you've got
a good looking girl I want to try you
and potentially want to delete you buff
so I think that girls don't really women
just don't really think about that but
you you know a cognitive of the fact
that when you're on your own and when
you're out there in the world is
dangerous and stuff like that but when
you've actually got a man there that you
can rely on that is there for you that
you can you know he's gonna be your 999
bro like I think women need to
understand that and respect that and
show more respect to their men for the
fact that usually a man will be more
willing to risk his life for his woman
so I'm saying women don't women how many
women have laid down their lives for
their man it don't exist you're saying
that women can't really equate to that
commitment women don't do it that's what
I'm saying women don't do it
and I think that's very undervalued and
not even represented all women really
talk about these days I want a man that
makes six figures
is that is that what it it really boils
down to you bro
you know what I'm saying like bro when
you're walking down the road with your
man you're clutching his arm bro like
who's he who's who clutching nobody but
he's got himself
Julie if there's if you're in the house
with your man there's a bump downstairs
who's going downstairs man
that's it bro who usually dies in horror
films first it's the man broth
everybody's trying their best to save
the woman brav es so what are we
second-class citizens like we're
second-class humans this is what I'm
saying so a lot of women just don't
really rate men like that they don't
really care social protection be number
one and be like oh you're a bum but you
can protect me so I'll take you in yeah
what do you think
about cause I always think about that
because like that's never ever talked
about it's never taught and I think what
like I've had I've had this there was
one situation I remember yeah I was with
this girl and we went to the club it was
like I think it was my birthday and a
couple of my friends went out and I
remember some guys just like started
they was just chatting rubbish like
saying oh what's that what's that girl
doing with that waste man I was just
like bro like I had to rise up like
there was nothing else I could do
because she can't do nothing and she's
looking at me like yeah you're Batman
do you know what I'm saying like you're
Batman you're Superman you're Spider-Man
you gotta do the business like do you
know what I'm saying so I had to rise up
even though like at that point I was on
my own my friends had gone I was on my
own but I had to defend the situation
because if I didn't that would make us
both victims do you kept saying and at
the end of the day
like with me rising to the occasion but
I was putting myself in a dangerous
situation because there wasn't just one
guy
and I don't think women really aren't
don't because you lot don't live that
life you don't think about it bro you
just don't do it do you think that
they're
that there's always a situation that a
man has to protect a woman or there's
some situation to where like it can just
be
not push aside but just don't walk away
from the situation yeah there's
situations that you can walk away but
really and truly like this world is
dangerous in it so you have to be aware
that that element that that risk is
always there always you know what I'm
saying and again what I'm saying is I
think that a lot of women just do not
think about it because it's just not in
your bubble do you know what I'm saying
about men we are aware of it when we're
walking down the street at 3am we are
aware that like bro something could
happen like because if you guys get
attacked like it's you're cooked but if
we get attacked like at least another
man would probably protect us yeah if I
was getting beaten up a guy people will
watch if I was getting beaten up yeah
but like if I got beat up like even when
I was um when I had that girl like try
to attack me in shortage like guys were
kind like if if she did anything like
guys were the first ones to come none of
them really knew me and that was a girl
yeah and that was a girl not to talk
about if it was a guy you would get
weighed in yeah and be finished yeah you
know what I'm saying yeah no one's no
one's no one's coming to this the the no
no one's really coming to the aid of
guys like and I'm not saying it like oh
we need to look after I'm not saying
that but I'm just trying to make you not
understand what you're saying you'd be
like the men need to be protected at all
costs isn't it so yourself to provide
yeah but they do because if you're the
protector and you need to be that you
need to be protected is that's what
you're basically saying no I'm just
saying that women be saying I'm saying
that women need to understand the role
that men play and how important that is
it's not just recognize and appreciate
yeah you're saying that women don't seem
to want to submit to a man unless he
makes a certain amount of money but we
don't appreciate the protection that he
provides because if there is if there is
a blackout tomorrow I think every girl
would be running to their friend zone
and saying please I agree yeah but I'm
not one of those women I'm not one of
those women that think that women don't
need a man
do you know what I mean I'm old school
and I just feel like two they there's
parts that we we provide to them and
they provide for us I agree do you know
what I mean yeah I feel like women are
just more delicate there's things that
we need to be protected more it's even
in Wildlife do you understand you
protect the women and the kids do you
get me I'm I'm more I'm more delicate
I'm more softer than you I'm not as
strong as you so if it comes down to the
Warren who's gonna have to fight if we
have to pick out a me and you you're
gonna have to be the one that's gonna
have to fight for us isn't it no it goes
do you understand and then I protect the
kids the children after you then it
comes to me but all I'm saying is that
because the initial um point we was
talking about is that oh if you're going
50 50 monetary wise
um does does it make you like basically
50 50 the whole way through it's not 50
50 the whole way through it's not it's
not because just as you said if you go
to war who's going me or you me that's
that's leaving do you think modern women
are lazy
lazy in terms of what to do housework
and stuff
they don't want to do it yeah because
that's the thing like we have more
automation than we've ever had
absolutely but I hear more complaints
about doing it than we ever have when
they used to have to hand wash clothes
yep
they go off or what
um ice cream right what you said about
how your old school and you um just I
can't remember a thing you said but what
you just said about being old school a
lot of
women have taken that mindset in the
role like I need to do this for myself I
need to provide I need to be the
masculine so that that essence of being
old school wanting to be feminine
wanting to just be a woman in a sense is
very slim to none and a lot a woman and
it's not until late that they realize
hmm maybe I should retract how I've been
acting in the masculine way to be able
to attract what I want and then there's
some that's like no why would I why
would I lower myself to attract a man
when a man needs to be XYZ to be able to
attract me I think a wife's a wife
before she's a wife
do you understand I agree so there's
certain characteristics you can't meet
somebody and then when they then you
show them who you are because then
they're not going to make you a wife
when a man like you said what you bring
to the table
um I do think the women are at the table
if a man reads meets the right woman she
will add value to that man that's
non-tangible and that's just that on
that that's what I believe what value
value to a man that's non-tangible that
means he will become ten times more
valuable than he was before she met like
these characteristics the way he is
certain things that make him a great man
money isn't the only thing that makes
him a great man the right woman makes
you want to do better be better create a
family create a legacy build and create
together that's what I think I think
that's a narrative that we've sold women
to make us feel like we're more valuable
than we are like for example I think
most billionaires that even if they've
been married with their wife for 20 30
years they seem like good women and they
get a divorce like they're usually fine
after they're still doing great things
Jeff Bezos
um same with Microsoft guy like I don't
I don't think I think men are great and
if like a great man's gonna be a great
man regardless if he has a woman or not
it depends on what is Genghis Khan I
think would still conquer the world even
if he didn't have a Mane I don't know
what Einstein would have still done what
he was doing
I didn't say that they wouldn't I just
said if you have the right woman beside
you you're even better that's what I
think well I think sure like I think
it's better to have the right woman but
I don't I don't think they really play a
part in a man's success not not really I
do like I think I think that like hard
working like my dad even though my mom
like helped him build his business and
she did help a lot
um I would still say he would have done
the same thing even without her okay
like because the woman helps navigate a
man's thought process and certain things
if he listens to her as well as certain
times that's just me I feel like the man
is the head the woman is the neck and I
feel like there's certain things that a
woman can see in hindsight sometimes
that a man can't see he's more logical
she's more emotional and stuff but I
feel like she instills certain things in
him that he doesn't have and when when
you have the right woman that can help
you to grow with you and build with you
you'll be more of a principal person
more of a principal person listen bro I
just think like this year there is a
certain level of synergy that that is uh
good between you know when you're in a
relationship when you're when you're
with a good woman but the woman doesn't
necessarily make him a better man
brother he is what he is
do you know what I'm saying so I I just
I just don't agree with that at all and
then you said and then also you said the
woman then you also said the woman is
the table how did you come to that
that's what I believe yeah but I just
feel like a woman basically a man will
can become even more greater with a
woman beside him so how does that make
her the table I think if you'd like
specifically describe it like how like a
woman is the person you know like they
say like you give her a house and she
creates a home you give her food she
creates a dinner plate you plant the
seed she gives you a child she's able to
create things out of whatever you give
her you understand what I'm saying no
she's a support she's not a table she's
that's my opinion it's just no I feel
you you can I think that there is any
you know you can say what you think
that's just my business what would make
more sense is that you you work together
I think what you're saying sounds more
like your two pieces of the same of a
pie in it like your two sides of a pie
but when you say it's the table it kind
of sounds like the woman is the Bo endo
and the guy's just the The Cameo
character Brothers he does when you say
the table because the table is the the
epicenter of the of everything in that
in that um scenario in that situation
yeah that's where the dinner's on there
we're the ones that have the babies and
everything I just feel like we are the
table
where the table you probably brings the
chairs he brings everything to us
[Music]
I mean like the man built the house and
sure you can add decorations and make it
at home he built the house
what can a man get from a woman that he
can't get from a cook hmm a maid and a
hooker
if that was out of stone I don't know I
don't just think it says clean cut I
don't think it's as clean cut as that I
just want to cook I just wanna do you
understand what I'm saying because
there's energy there there's chemistry
there there's a relationship there
mm-hmm yeah no no no I don't I don't
know you just think that a man would
just just get a cook just get a cleaner
yeah
and that's okay I don't know if that's
what I'm not saying that's okay just
saying like if that's that what does a
woman offer like I'm saying that the men
are on the table I don't think the women
are the table I think the men are the
table and the women can come along for
the ride and they can either come or
they can most women don't want to be The
Driver they want to be in the side Club
you know what I'm saying they want to be
in a nice ride they don't want to be The
Driver they don't want to buy the car
and drive the car they want to be riding
shotgun bro how can you be the table
from the Sidecar how can you be the
leader from the sidecar you can't broth
like like you don't even protect the
side like I think
I can understand
what you're saying isn't not the table
in the aspect as we know what the table
is how females say oh I'm the table I
bring everything but it's more of
looking at what does what is the aspect
of a table it's a support so if
say you needed to step on it to do
something better that she's there to
support him she's like she's able to
support
you put so the aspect of a table is to
support whatever you put on it and so if
a man needs to elevate whatever a
woman's there to support him a woman's
there to support whatever is placed
there uh like she said building a family
building
um a home XYZ she's there to support him
in his aspects is that kind of what you
were talking about with the table I kind
of understand it I don't I don't agree
with you see people are like the food on
the table that's what I'm saying because
the the table without the table there
which is the the origin without the
table there the foundation there's you
can't you can't put no food on air
you know what I'm saying so the man has
to for instance I'll give you the
example here the man buys the house
because we we said that in our examples
yeah the man buys the house yeah the
woman makes it a home right without the
bricks and the roof and the doors the
bruh you can bring all the decorations
from Ikea or whatever but there's no
house Ralph
so really and truly that's the table
buff
all them all them little things are just
extras all the little mirrors and the
love hope live crap on the wall that's
just that's nothing bro that's nothing
really and truly you can live in an
empty house
you can feel protected in an empty house
you're you're sheltered from the weather
in an empty house the decorations don't
mean [ __ ] they don't mean nothing like I
said I'm not talking just about the
Furnishings like just no but you said it
you make the woman makes the home yeah
it's just to me it doesn't just rely on
the furniture making a home is where
your kids come it's the energy that's in
there do you understand what I'm saying
it's where you feel like you're most
peaceful when you get home
do you know what I'm saying what was the
point like women make a man greater
so is that I feel like it was kind that
every successful man is a successor is a
strong woman I feel like a man can a man
that finds the right a man who finds the
right woman
there's loads of men
no no but I I think men are just a very
successful man is a bunch of women he's
[ __ ] crazy
in the front everywhere and this is this
is coming from like my dad was very
loyal but like no I don't think so like
I just think that men are great like the
the men that are gonna be great and
gonna be ultra productive are gonna do
that regardless of if there's a girl
there or not I don't think the girl
really does [ __ ] I just think those guys
are Workaholics they're usually very
conscientious they're on their path you
can either come or you can go that's it
I think men are literally designed to
succeed with or without women because
they're meant to be building buildings
and stuff do they really need a woman
okay now I'm gonna if we fundamental
like to build a like whole civilization
and a society
usually they they get their skills and
everything and they're succeeding it's
the woman is like
it's a an addition to that but he will
be consistent with his you know
greatness but I look at success in two
different things you keep speaking about
your you've built loads of people things
that doesn't make you a good man no no I
I just said that as an example that
means that when you let my people yeah
that is a great thing building no no but
I said I don't believe that that's that
is the that just you doing alone makes
you there's more there's more things to
you to me that make you a great man
that's what I that's what I think as
well anyway do you know what I mean
Auntie Jenny says behind not in front or
next to you women are supposed to
support the man not lead help me not
headache I agree okay I'm gonna take a
second to read some super chats
um guys all the super chats are going
towards getting an 8K camera also just a
reminder
the top Super Chat of this show we will
put your username behind me and then if
you have like a specific message you
want under it we're going to put it like
behind me for the next show it'll be on
like a little piece of paper or
something printed off
um so let's we're gonna also read super
chats um over ten dollars today so I'm
gonna start with those okay Starscream
the there are certain women need to
start there are certain women need to
start fights and put their man in
unnecessary dangerous women weaponize
men against other men as well
um a hundred dollar Super Chat top Super
Chat
um how many men are in jail coming to a
woman's age some after they investigated
and instigated a mess I'm gonna call my
cousins nem
um mgtow by Logic men do more housework
than ever before add that to the
machines men invented women are the
laziest they've ever been hence why
they're fatter than they've ever been
before Clifford range Pearl if you and
guests really want to understand simple
mentality go to Kittle pool section of
twitch
um Thane um Mitra Pearl it's not chai
tea chai equals T that's redundant Steve
Harvey is a Sim Master Watch his talk
show and advice to women for laughs oh
my gosh that's the next thing we're
going to react to after this
um mgtow by Logic hypergamy dictates
women date up which forces men to date
down and no one's crying that men have
to settle we eat [ __ ] burgers for 12
million years shut up and pick a man you
can only pick a man that picks you too
simple NSX Opposites Attract this is a
constant in the natural world why are
humans so special that you should
believe you need a clone as your partner
this old lady here to help Pearl and
help blessing get an 8K camera support
mail-centric content and cancel toxic
feminism
mgtow by Logic because nearly all women
are am are the embodiment of the
dunning-kruger effect that they can't
see their subpar they're complaining
there's no good men as if men don't
suffer the same problem fix yourself
vanity Rose he's he mixed in oz of Truth
with a pound of crap he's a snake oil
snails salesman that just says what he
knows they want to hear um
and not gonna lie our entire economy is
built on pandering to women advertising
marketing streaming social media relies
on them consuming their BS Deary simps
are like vultures they're there to pick
through the carcass leftovers from
predators AKA Bad Boys Matt butcher simp
a man who is overly and easily attached
and desperate to women verb to stimp the
act of simping despite the feelings not
being re reciprocated often to the point
of disrespect
um Andrea or
um oh I read that was last stream okay
guys Let me refresh it real quick make
sure you are liking the video like is
free we have over 2 000 people in here
tonight I think we should have at least
a thousand likes so make sure you hit
that like button
um the okay NSX I am the table in her
complex um symbiology is a hard cope to
avoid thinking about a real answer 20
minutes to convince two to three people
to kind of know what you mean then
congrats your man just went off to Ikea
for a new table
um Thane Matra I am the table replace
table with relationship and see how
delusional that sounds either that or
you literally mean your dry age age
seasoned oak or mahogany meh
um
Starscream there are women that need oh
I read that one already okay
um so blessing do you want to put the
next clip Up
oh can I just add something yeah go
ahead
um I just thought it would be
interesting to mention this Men actually
do better after a divorce and women do
significantly worse so it's just like oh
they you know they're
they were great and they need to
actually get greater after a divorce
and women actually plummet their
finances everything goes
as they hit the wall
yeah and I think also when I actually
realized like that you know they can
actually keep that money invest it make
that grow and they you know it's because
it's not going into a black hole
fortunately
so that's something to think about
oh
what about the women who
essentially get 50
from their uh husband or take everything
from them does that still equate to them
the man still like after gets up off his
feet and does he still do well and the
woman still does batter is it yeah yeah
because he he can manage his money
better and it's not you know um let's
just say you've had like a surplus or
anything he can reinvest that as because
it goes back it links to women being the
biggest consumers she's got her divorce
she's gonna sorry I keep doing that
thing boy she's gonna get her hair done
and her nails like she's feeding her
allergy I got divorced I'm gonna go
spend all my money
there's divorce parties now oh yeah
which is so like sad yeah and they go
out they go all out and I'm like that's
all your alimony money
so the irony but yeah
here's a question when do you think it's
appropriate to start splitting the bill
on dates I am more than happy to go
dutch I believe in equality for all so I
I like the ying and the Yang of a guy
pan sometimes I'll pay sometimes it kind
of sets the tone for a relationship and
you know I got your back you got my back
having said that if it is the first date
he better offer to pay or there will not
be a second base
well I will say I love it as a gesture I
think it's really sweet and I appreciate
it but a lot of times I feel like no I
want to go dutch on the first date
because we're both feeling each other
out and I don't want someone to assume
something so I I like to end up in the
first day well
I mean
I feel like it just depends on the
delivery right yes like if the check
comes and he looks over at me like yeah
yeah then so you need to you need to go
ahead and put down on this and I'm gonna
go
um not never to be seen again but I
think I think that needs to be discussed
early on right like how how much of a
date is this are we still are you
interested in courting me for real or
did you did you ask me out or did I ask
you out or was this like a setup by
friends I feel like those things need to
be discussed early on communication will
eliminate any room forever in that
situation yes
have we done this poor of a job with our
young men yeah yeah have we have we not
talked our younger men
but this is really supposed to be about
I'm sorry the way it is supposed to work
and I can appreciate everything you all
are saying because you women so quite
naturally you set the tone for how you
are
but let me say this to men
it's the it's the proper thing to do
it's the right thing to do and it's the
way it should be done
you got a lot of nerve you know dudes
kill me because we got a lot of nerve
thinking this thing is 50 50. because I
got news for you it ain't they happen to
have a skill set that you'll never
possess they can produce another human
life
there's nothing you can do can come
close to that I'm ashamed of men who
don't understand them in addition to
that part of the conversation it needs
to be made clear to men that women don't
owe you when you take us to dinner just
because you buy me dinner just because
you paid the valet doesn't mean I need
to go home with you absolutely so that
in that same conversation that still
needs to be said and I think that's why
so many women still want to pay because
you don't want to be bought because you
don't want the perception of the
obligation exactly because now I am not
for sale correct yeah because nowadays A
lot of times in this situation the women
might be making more money then he need
to play in the playground he qualified
to play
foreign
[Music]
to be a provider you were born to put a
woman on a pedestal and treat her like a
queen that's your job as a man now if
you don't want the job go do something
else it's an honor to take a woman out
hey that is true
this pissed me off right here
[Applause]
ladies I'm sorry I'm sorry
look at all these men I've been looking
at this man right here with the lady
next and lady in the teal is that your
husband
this dude been getting he been going
yeah the whole time that dude up there
with the lady with the with the sad show
he was going yeah because he that man
with the blue t-shirt on with the lady
with the green t-shirt I've been looking
at all these men going yeah cause we
know
try this work y'all getting tricked man
these young dudes out here man if you
don't understand that and don't email
the show tomorrow see you got money
Steve ain't always had money I start I
had nothing I have never ever in my life
from every date I've ever went on and
Adam been on some dates
had a woman pay for nothing for me
different time different times this was
when I was good in Pope if I'd had the
money I saved it so I could take out
I'm sorry man all right we gotta take a
break we got more straight talk when we
come oh my God can there be two king of
simps I think Derek's been dethroned oh
my God
why tell me why that was that was too
much man first of all how old is he I
don't know 40s no no oh my God
he's on the way it's a different
freaking time it's like
how can you say that oh yeah you know I
didn't have a job before I was broke oh
yeah every single day I paid it was
probably it was much more less than it
is now there's just so many things to
consider and he's not even yeah that was
yeah that was again offensive yeah and
like they didn't I mean as Michael was
saying earlier like I don't think the
women then were sleeping with the other
guy we're going yeah that was like true
courtship yeah beating to a serious
relationship marriage commitment all
that good stuff
yeah all of the guys and couples that he
pointed to in the audience looked old
I can't see anyone that looks like sex
they looked like soup they look weak you
know their wives brought them to that oh
absolutely and he knows he has to clap
Bradford yeah bro you're using old
people as a measuring stick for the
current Society it doesn't correlate so
it doesn't it doesn't work bro and like
again he's saying oh don't email because
you're saying I've got money but you do
have money though we talking about bro
in the UK the the energy prices have
gone up considerably house prices have
gone up considerably is not easy bro
do you know what I'm saying like I
really can't stand these people that act
like everybody's balling we're not all
living some uh rock star life it's
unrealistic bars yeah and like at the
end of the day he's talking about oh
yeah this is an honor what do you mean
bro the woman is a stranger bro and and
with that all that advice yeah oh yeah
you need to pay on a first date make
sure the date is cheap bro every guy
watching this year let me tell you keep
the check the date cheap then it ain't
gonna it ain't gonna hurt you bro
maximum 50 pound maximum Max I agree
because if I like a guy I don't give a
[ __ ] where he takes me if you if you
really like it like if you're really
into a guy you don't give a [ __ ] he
could take you to freaking make that if
you really like him like you might you
might you know wish it wasn't McDonald's
but you're still just happy to be there
yeah you're happy to be there yeah
inside you're gonna be like oh I wish
you took me to a little restaurant but
you're not gonna care bro I'm telling
you on one hand the amount of girls that
I've taken out on a date like a proper
date like one hand bro and those girls
were already my girlfriend bruv
so I've already found out or or like the
realization has come that she actually
likes me and she's invested in one way
maybe not monetary but she's invested
she's invested time energy there's no
one word answer replies like she's
actually showing enthusiasm to get to
know me and that and show me that she
likes me bro that's somebody yeah okay
boom I can take you out but not for some
stranger bro and all of that is a lie
bro and they're trying to turn the
majority of men into Sims they're trying
to feminize uh men mention that have a
backbone we shouldn't have an idea or a
perspective on anything this is whatever
the woman wants it goes bro you got
stupid idiots like Steve Harvey 99 of
his audience are women all clapping old
old women clapping yeah like what are
you talking about bro it's propaganda
it's nonsense bro you know what I'm
saying so at the end of the day he's
just the same he's just trying to make
money I understand get your bag but bro
anybody with half a brain will
understand that this is this is BS bro
do you think women owe men sex if he's
taken her out of multiple nice dates
I wouldn't say oh that's that's a strong
word oh that's like deserve see what I'm
saying no one deserves anything and I
don't think a woman owes a man sex but
at the same time bro like everything is
in exchange in this world bro like if
you're if you're if you're dating a guy
you know the guy wants to sleep with you
I don't care how nice he is to you I
don't care how how he talks to you you
know he wants to sleep with you bro so
if you're dating a guy and you know you
don't want to sleep with him you
shouldn't be dating him RAV
that's it
I mean other people might not agree with
that but why why would you be seeing a
guy that you have no intention of
sleeping with them eventually so what
you're just going to be dating and
dating and dating him he's going to be
wasting my time and money for what for a
girl that's not interested this is what
I'm saying this is why I can count on
one hand the amount of girls that have
actually gone out there and spent proper
money on a date for those girls were
already my guilt
and guys need to understand because
guess what that girl that you're
spending 200 300 pound on on a
restaurant at hakasan or Gaucho yeah
that girl is sleeping with a guy for
free
hundred percent the outside so it's all
right I'm not trying to hear any of that
bro serious and I've been that guy to
sleep with girls for free many times bro
you know what I'm saying Jim dates bear
gym dates come on man
gem dates yeah gym dates
get me
what is it a gym day okay boom let's say
yeah yeah workout together oh okay okay
let's work out together or um what's it
even even simple let's go to the the uh
shopping center just walk around they
worked out with you and they wanted to
hook up after switch Yeah like obviously
I'm wearing the best than that
he's like yelling at them and stuff no
I'm not actually training them I'm not
training them they're like we're going
there together like you know what I'm
saying yeah I'm gonna go there anyway
it's real like that and again it's just
like what you said if the girl if the
girl likes you it doesn't matter where
you go bro yeah I agree so true that's
so true take me to Popeyes and talk to
me that's all I want I want chick
sandwich and everything more time
exactly more time you eat one sandwich
have one drink the drink will you you
drink half the drink you'll be there for
like two hours just talking because you
actually like the guy you're interested
in the guy when these girls talk about a
guy has to pay this and he has to take
me here that's for the guys they don't
really like they use it that's what it
is yeah I don't I don't think it's
always like
conscious you know like but I do think
like a lot of times like women were so
indecisive that it's like like I don't
know sometimes guys get taken advantage
of you know
you're saying guys get taken advantage
of because what women are indecisive
okay
I mean I think I
like personally I don't have a ton of
free time so like I wouldn't I think my
time's valuable so if I don't like a guy
I'm not gonna go on a date with him but
I think a lot of guys like wait for
years in the friend zone and I think as
women like we kind of know this and
sometimes like it
feeling but he's in the friend zone for
a reason because you know you don't like
him so he's not indecisive you just
don't like him he's just there yeah
that's true he's doing it to himself
really yeah that's true what do you
think of guys that stay in the friend
zone idiots sad but the girl but more
time the guy knows but he's just I don't
know he's been watching Aladdin or
Sleeping Beauty or something bro I don't
know bro you've been listening to Derek
Jackson or Steve Harvey I don't know
what it is but you need to understand if
the girl's sending you one word answers
if she's taking
24 hours to reply to her message she
don't like you she's piping letting
somebody else Piper bro that's it move
on find a girl that that does like you
an uncomfortable truth is for a lot of
guys is that more time like this is not
my honest opinion more time the girls
that you like don't like you that's
uncomfortable but that's just the
reality because just like what you
always say on the dating apps what women
swipe right how many times
um women's right between five and like
15 percent of the time where men swipe
right 50 roughly there you go there you
go yeah so that's the reason that's the
reason like women hate men and like they
say things like men are trash and like
men are the problem and even like men
need to rise up it's usually because
they're sleeping out of their league
because it's like a girl that's a five
six maybe seven sleeping with an eight
nine or ten and then they'll say oh like
men don't do enough but no it's because
you're picking the guy that's out of
your league and you're getting plan C
attention because that's where you're at
oh and another thing what Steve Steve
saw the simpy said yeah is that oh well
if you're trying to date a woman that's
out of your league then play in your own
playground well guess what the women in
that guy's playground probably still
want to date a guy that's higher than
him anyway so it still doesn't equate
and that's that's the thing like those
women like how many are 120. that are
that are in that income bracket
I don't know they might be I don't know
but it's like he's equating the same
like like that men and women have the
same type of Standards when they don't
and they obviously don't yeah and so
it's like just because a girl's
successful
if she if she only goes for guys that
are above her should probably be lonely
yeah he wasn't even he was even
differentiating women he just said women
you know right like he didn't say
successful with me he says oh well maybe
she's at your league what are you
talking about a lot of generalization
yeah man even in the wedding though they
say it's the it's the bride's day like
the guys
the guy just turns up and and he
probably paid for everything the napkins
and napkin holders and whatever she's
like a bride's day and even they say
happy wife happy life oh yeah wow and I
see that in the store you know that's
what they filled their house with and
stuff like she's always right like why
do we have terms like that
and it's like haha as seen as the guy
you know I don't know there's like
merchandise for the guy it's just like
it's just wrong
yeah and would you guys care would you
get married in a courthouse no never
ever
sorry sorry okay would you get married
like a small ceremony where it's just
either like legally or just never
legally but yeah small ceremony small
ceremony yeah and I'd have an intimate
wedding
like no no dress no nothing just like
we're married
gym tracks
equivalent would be but like I'm
thinking of the reason I asked the
courthouse wedding wasn't necessarily
because of like it's intimate I was
talking about like a lot of women get
married for the wedding and not that
show of it and not for a husband and so
like if you got rid of the wedding would
you still want to get married yeah
that's a great question or money in my
pocket this is too much so I think too
it's like all all of that money all that
extravagantness for maybe 20 minutes for
people to see you walk down that yes
it's beautiful yes it's great but it's
like why why all of this when you can
just show you can have the same feel
show the love that you have for the
person that you're getting married to in
a smaller aspect a cheaper aspect and
then if you all want to go have fun
afterwards go meet up somewhere it's
just a lot of weddings are very showing
it's like do you need all that to just
say I do
it's just like when you did that video
but with that black chick when she said
that well how much was the engagement
300 000 engagement 200 wow
give me a ring pop blueberry
but that's the thing it's like you're a
very used Honda Civic and you want you
want new BMW prices but if you sold
yourself at used Honda Civic prices you
might get a good buyer but instead the
dating coaches are saying raise your
standards but it's like women you can't
raise your standards the older you get
like because you're less valuable in the
market and you might you might find a
sucker but do you really want a sucker
there you go I I know a crazy crazy
story
um and it kind of interlinks with
everything anyway there was this woman
um my sister knows her
um she was I think 32 or something and
um you know she was like thinking about
marriage and things like that she didn't
have anybody she literally turned to her
friend her guy friend and said
um oh you know she was like you know
venting to him like oh I can't find
anyone I really want to get married and
he goes I'll marry you
and they got married
she had the huge wedding like you know
the fancy dress and all that stuff and
she's still married and she doesn't love
him and her family doesn't know and
they're waiting for grandchildren
and they're like why why aren't their
grandchildren
he's an idiot because he thinks that oh
yeah one day she'll fall in love with me
and she just used him literally for the
wedding is he beating though what does
that mean oh right uh I I don't know but
can you imagine she she that's bunk
[ __ ] she she's the type of person you
know she's she's a she's she's uh you
know she has a career and everything
like that she just wanted the freaking
wedding and now she's so one day she's
married him for five years she's a
narcissist isn't that nuts like I would
I would like I just don't care I've
never cared about a wedding but that's
how insane like they can get about the
wedding like to me 10K at a wedding I'm
just like that's a lot of money yeah
what can you do you see Asia for that
that's a deposit up Norful you could get
a house yeah
what why did you say you would never get
married in court
well because uh
it's probably the least romantic thing
you could ever do uh because
um you know you let's just say it goes
to divorce then the government the state
will just treat you like your two
business partners and then um you know
you would have somebody to divide your
you know your hard-earned money and your
assets so is there a way to get
married without the
courts uh if you are if you're allowed
to talk about it oh yeah yeah sure it's
just uh because I think about the US a
lot and then I think about the UK and
obviously it's different but um so in
the US unfortunately and my heart goes
out to you know the men if you cohabit
they treat you as if you are you know
married in some sense you know in terms
of the woman can say you know I want
alimony I want but they weren't even
married you didn't have a marriage
contract so what is this
um because a lot of people will cohabit
not to go into that so if the woman so
then you can like amicably you know like
okay this is how much you're taking and
um she could even say yeah yeah I'll do
that but then she just goes to the
courthouse
and then they treat it as a marriage so
your your assets will be divided as if
you're married
however in the UK now uh you could uh
cohabit common law marriage as it's as
known it's not recognized as a state
marriage so that's actually something
that we need to protect in the in the UK
but you know that the the women they're
like no we want we want like a religious
ceremony
um to be the same as a state like
marriage
why why why why would they want that
security insurance
policy so what are you saying I need to
know this information hold on let me get
this straight so you see it
so if you get said in the UK yeah like I
I can cohabit with a woman and then if
we break she can't ask for nothing yeah
and unless unless unless and it's this
makes sense unless you have a child and
then you know you have yeah but that's
always sticky if you have a child yeah I
know but I just want to make that
because people probably think they'll
just get confused but that's what
something that has to be protected and I
really wish that the US had this um
like the cohabitation thing like just
mashing them together as if you're
married you know synonymous is very
wrong of course
um and we have that in the UK that's
something to be happy about that is
protected so a man an adult man an adult
woman they can negotiate media together
and you know come up with something by
themselves instead of having like a
completely foreign third party just not
dictating yeah and that's actually worse
for the children see mommy and daddy
fighting and all that stuff is horrible
but like I said it's under threat at the
moment because there are loads of
organizations and
you know like yeah anyway
um led by women
um and uh saying that no if you get a
religious ceremony let's just say so
it's not state
you it would just automatically be seen
at the State marriage and and they say
there's there's one organization I don't
know if I can mention it so I won't
mention it but they say in the website
it's like
um because we have seen
um too many women being taken advantage
of but what does that
means that's gas yeah women have been
taken advantage of yeah
because it's cheaper to keep her because
no I think it's because they they see if
it was a state marriage you'll be closer
to getting 50 right uh and if it's like
Amic Liberty it's like okay what what
did you contribute to the marriage and
usually it will be much less than what
the man contributed because he fulfilled
the the fundamental needs
um and I'm not like downplaying what a
woman brings but in terms of them kind
of you know deciding who takes what it's
a lot it's a lot more fair but the thing
is
um equality doesn't mean I think now the
families are trying to say equity which
is quite sneaky like Equity what was the
difference
did you want to chime I heard someone
say that I think it was yesterday or
something it was on your shower so I was
losing my mind I was like no it's like
it's just basically
it's basically just equality when it
benefits like let's just be did you know
what it is it's it's it's basically
um
okay it's equality of outcome
so they recognize that now they're
recognizing saying equality isn't isn't
enough because we'll be called out
because as women we aren't the same as
men we can't do as much hours and all
that stuff right so we're not equal
however I want equity which means I I'll
get the same outcome does that make
sense so if I go and that's the worst
thing I think one of your guests said
that she's she believes in equity I
don't think she knew what she was
talking about no I was losing my mind
she saw a picture with like boxes and
looking over a fence yeah I don't and
and she mentioned that individuals
that's not a good analogy yeah because
thing is literally all I can say is who
gives her the boxes
where did the boxes come from the man
yeah it doesn't make it fair yeah so
yeah that's the thing like women are so
oblivious to the fact that like men bail
us out of all of our bad decisions yeah
like historically we couldn't even be
single
like we literally couldn't survive being
single but like who protects us the
police men firemen
yeah people that build the building like
we wouldn't be able to do any of this
without men
trust me women don't want it to be no
Wild Wild West out here trust me they
don't want that
um I think I'm gonna close out the show
oh
um
well I'm gonna read the super chats real
quick if you guys have any final
thoughts anything you want to speak your
piece on
channels Pages you want to plug you know
do that in a second
so guys
um make sure you like the video that is
the most important metric that YouTube
uses to push out these streams I believe
our Channel sponsor
her stream sponsor today is let me look
let me look
um Thane um Mitra so
um you I think he donated 200 to 300
this stream yeah big shout out
big man come on so um if you DM me on
Instagram if you have something specific
you want me to like write on a piece of
paper that's going to go behind me
um you're gonna be on the next stream
otherwise it's just gonna be um your
username so either or
um my Instagram is just dot pearlythings
or you can email me justpirelythings
gmail.com okay so um rock Liggins if
your wife is Happy she'll nag you less
and give you space happy wife happy life
mgtow by Logic women are chunky gym
dates not dinner dates if she protects
if she protests I just saved you a
hundred dollars minimum the the Kenny B
um Steve has done has done money since
his early 20s and was buying host Stakes
when they were 4.99 These Hoes want Ruth
Chris now um vanity Rose the funny
um the funny of this is that a woman
the funny thing is all of those women
clapping for Steve are paying for their
EX for his ex-wife he's not a simp he's
a con man the longer the longer they
stay in pain the longer he lives in Fame
SMH mgtel by Logic Steve let's look at
that daughter of yours yeah that's what
I thought shut up
old lady um don't take the first date if
you are not sexually attracted to him
that is theft his time and money she
even said it doesn't don't expect sex
then don't take the date mgtow by Logic
have we not failed our men Steve 80
percenter kids are born out of wedlock
the or the dad is forced out before the
kid is 10 years old it's women screwing
women screwing up the boys not men
you're a clown marriage causes divorce
um Sahara is wrong the UK generally lose
the UK men generally lose at Route 70
plus lose monthly child support if if
the man has a surplus the judge will
order spousal support to I lost 70
percent
um mgtow by Logic my divorce is the best
thing to happen to me in the last 15
years cut out all the waste dead weight
gone literally Ethan was here women make
self-conscious make men self-conscious
which forces us to create confront
reality they Orient us from with their
judgment a boy becomes a man when he
realizes that his duty is to the Future
women alert us to that selection NSX I
am the table
um oh wait I read that one Let me
refresh it real quick just to make sure
there aren't any other super chats guys
also um don't forget to like the video I
believe there's almost 3 000 of you in
here at one point there's only 1.1 legs
come on we should we should at least get
2 000 before the stream ends
push out this content come on come on
um I like a like is free a like is free
um rock uh Liggins oh wait I read that
one okay so um you want to start final
thoughts oh and go around
I don't know a lot to say
um
yeah
I don't know I don't say don't don't get
illegal marriage that's all I can say oh
if you want to um connect with me my
Instagram is Shahara Isla
uh yeah
um I don't really have much to say but
follow me on Instagram speedy.s22
um final thoughts uh
hmm
listen and listen carefully to what
things that people say just don't take
it because they're on a platform or
because they the majority are rooting
them on be secure in who you are and
make sure that you're the person that
you need to be before you even interact
with anybody else or try to
be with anybody else and you can find me
on YouTube and Instagram at your girl
justly
uh first thing I just want to say it's
been a pleasure being on this podcast
with all these ladies here
um
listen just like just said just don't
just don't give in or just listen to any
old crap out there because just because
it makes you feel good you know what I'm
saying like bro like always kind of
weigh up things what logically makes
sense and what is kind of like a bit off
the wall
um because there's a lot of people out
here that they're just trying to make
money and they don't care if they're
gonna lie to you or sell you a drink
they don't care yeah and anyway
um yeah you can follow me on uh
Instagram Ambitions of power on
Instagram and also go and subscribe to
my YouTube channel King riches the links
in the description below I think so make
sure you go subscribe and peace out
um you can follow me on Instagram Ice
Cream the poster girl please follow my
YouTube Queen ice cream TV
um stay true to your beliefs and um yeah
that's me
okay guys thank you to the panel good
good show today
[Music]
um okay guys um a couple announcements
before we end the stream um the first
being go follow our two clips channels
just pearly clips and pearl daily we
have two different editors on those
accounts and
um they're pretty cool so you should go
follow them
um also oh and we just hit I forgot to
even announce this we just hit 100K on
one of our Clips Channel yeah yeah they
can't they come in hot that's good
um also um we have four membership tiers
the first um it gets you to be a part of
the chat the second gets to be the part
of the Discord and you get to our behind
the scenes Vlogs also my sister is
helping me with discords there's gonna
be cool stuff she's really into it
um our third tier you get to connect
with us on social media and our fourth
tier
um you get a one-on-one call with me
once a month I recommend this um if you
need help with a YouTube channel and you
want to grow on social media um I have
helped people get ten thousand twenty
thousand thirty thousand subscribers so
I would recom and that tier on top of
that go follow my Instagram just dot
pearly things you have to type out the
whole thing in order for my name to come
up because I am Shadow band go follow my
two Tick Tock accounts just
pearlythings.4 and dot five
um and also we're gonna have a Members
Only Live soon
um also go follow auntie and Michael's
channels they're in the description of
this video don't forget to like the
video on your way out and we will talk
to you next time
[Music]